under Allah peace be with you those are
greetings of peace the best greetings
and we are greeting you with it and our
next guest from punk rock I'm talking
about you know that's that stuff that
you get a guitar and you Bob your head
and you just you know lose your mind
this guy went went from punk rock to
this way of life that brings peace
happiness contentment you live in the
purpose of life you know why you're here
you know when you're going when you die
we're going to hear his story here on
the Dean show so don't go nowhere
assalamualaikum why they corset out a
lot of Atilla greetings of peace exact
laughs hey how are ya thank you very
much for I know it's your interview but
I'm asking you Harry I'm done all praise
to the critter to have as an ER fight
but you're gonna fine I tell the people
you won't find a group of people who are
more ecstatic about praising God is that
it you ask well so he can have the worst
day in his life he's like it hamdulillah
exactly prays to the crater exactly is
that right that's absolutely true
amen so you have a very interesting
story sad I do I do i graduated from
Edina I recently graduated about a years
ago graduate from the University of
Modena yes yeah now I know we don't go
into we'd read a lot of the things from
our past but a lot of times we speak
about it
to relate to the people so we can say
look I've been there done that that
doesn't bring happiness it brings misery
yeah used to be in a punk rock band used
to love music did you wake up to it mmm
yeah I think I did slow to it yeah
definitely slept to it that was like the
shakedowns Quran right definitely talk
to us about it what happened okay before
I tell you before I say anything I've
actually never really told this story
publicly so if you wonder if you're
watching this you're the first time is
the first time telling you public only
on the D show see you getting in here
only on the D but okay so basically my
story like it's very similar to a lot of
kids who grew up in America went to
public school in high school basically
just forward to high school I started a
band it's a punk rock band like punk
rock music you're the lead singer I was
the I don't know if you'd call it
singing punk rock so you know it's not
really singing but yeah I did I did lead
vocals guitar no not really okay I just
just lead vocals did lead vocals my band
was you know was pretty political so I I
kind of in the back of my mind I felt
like I was doing something good because
it was political and I spoke about real
issues and stuff like that I supposed to
like pop music and stuff like that for
me it was like you don't speak about
political issues
people who are oppressed and stuff like
that so I felt like I'm doing something
good so yeah that's where it started I
wasn't a punk rock band it lasted
throughout high school I when I went to
college that's when things began to
change for me when I went to college I
had a couple experiences in my life
people started asking me my brother
started asking me about life and is the
first time I actually began to question
what my life was about
so I began thinking about the purpose of
my life what it's all for
and it's actually one experience I had
no power yet decisions this was at the
beginning of college so I'd say about 18
you're 8 to 17 18 around that age it's
it's been a while so now 18 you're
thinking about purpose of life yeah
so the thing with me was I would write
lyrics for the band I was I I thought of
myself as somebody who was spiritual to
begin with I try to think deeper because
you know if you're a poet or lyricist
you know you tend to think deeply about
stuff so even when writing lyrics and
stuff like that I tried to stay away
from the cliches and you know write
about real issues so I would always I
had kind of had that spiritual side but
I never took it all the way where
actually asked myself like what's the
purpose of my life and it's only when
people started asking me and question me
Muslims as Muslims making Dow it to me
by the way I don't even really consider
myself most of them before I started
practicing it's done because I didn't
pray I never really even thought about
God so I'm not even sure if I really
believed in God your parents bring you
up is emotion I was brought up as a
Muslim I was in a Muslim household but
you know the way my parents were they
never really forced religion upon us
would they practice in Frankfort today
they're not cultural it was it was more
cultural nobody was really that
practicing the first person start
practicing sin was actually my brother
mhm and we're in the rituals that they
did you know how a lot of times you know
Muslims will come up they don't even
know what they're saying yeah
meaning behind it was never like it was
actually like that you know I would say
I said I wanna come out say inshallah I
I don't even know if I said insha'Allah
to be honest yeah now that I think about
it you know it's just something you say
this is very common isn't it yeah it is
pretty common it is pretty common I
remember I pray on aid pray Jamaat
yeah Ramadan you fast but you kind of
like to something you do right like you
don't know really why you're doing it
[ __ ]
I think most people think it's part of
their culture it's part of the culture
just something you do so that's how it
was for me I just didn't really even
think about it it wasn't like you know I
didn't want to be Muslim or anything
like that I just did I didn't think
about it I didn't care
you know just too busy in trying to get
the most out of this life and that's
what really caught me is when people
start asking me or my brother actually
he's first person started practicing in
my house and he would ask me he'd asked
me these deep questions that I really
needed to think about like what would
you like for example what's gonna happen
after you die I mean the average person
doesn't think about death and I remember
till now I was making Dawa to this after
I started practicing a friend of mine
from before I started practicing and I
asked him I said I said do you think
about death like what's gonna happen I
asked him the same question what's gonna
happen after he dies like listen don't
talk about about death that's too morbid
like I don't want to think about that
stuff I just want to enjoy life and have
fun and that's how I was too you know I
was like listen I don't
I still remember people ask me I'd be
like I said I don't I said I do my thing
you know it's gonna have fun enjoy life
you're ruining the height now yeah yeah
exactly the problem was I at that point
I did believe that this life did contain
everything right and it's only when I
came to the realization that this life
does not contain anything and that for
me happened at a particular moment it
happened at a time that I went to a
concert yeah and I'll tell you about
that you went to a concert I went to a
concert and something happened there
which was I would say that one of the
turning points for me now before we go
to break tell us so were you content
were you happy from a young age now
you're going to publish you want to
publish now in public school no you went
to high school yeah
and your friends they were just doing
the same thing obviously yeah are you
trying to fit in with a popular guy or
you were looking up to someone you were
trying to be who are you identifying
with okay so here's the thing in in
middle school I wasn't that popular and
when I went to high school I began to
find a little bit of an identity I read
the Autobiography of Malcolm X and I was
like you know what there's something to
this Islam thing and I began to build an
identity as like you know I was proud
like I like I was proud to be rebellious
and like I wrote that in my music you
know and that kind of that did make me
popular you know and then being in a
band that helped my popularity what but
it stopped there I used it for the means
of just being popular and you know
having a good time instead of taking it
the step further why it's punk rock it's
part well it's rock rock it's rock which
makes me rock is punk rock there's
different types of rock there's just
heavy metal punk rock you know there's a
Aesop Rock this classic rock did you'll
get into a little R&B hip hop any
eventually I wasn't really in the RV to
me no not not really the only thing that
I listened to I listened to a little bit
of underground rap because it was
political yeah they were talking about
real issues social issues so a little
bit of underground rap I don't want to
throw out some nice this really takes
over your mind you're like music does
that pretty much I mean at that point I
had a bumper sticker on my car that said
I love music all right so basically I
wanted people to know that if you don't
know me
the one thing you can know about me is
that I love music it becomes like a way
of religion it really is you know the
celebrities yeah these are the people
that you're mimicking it's like I
remember the people dice look up to like
the person that I want to be were people
who were celebrities you know people who
celebrity tournament they're musicians
never rock stars or punk rock stars okay
we got more to talk about here in a dish
of the concert yeah yeah say about the
concert techmo so many celebrities here
on the Dean show from punk rock to true
purpose purpose in life be right back
and it's simple to understand I wouldn't
know what the sky looked like what the
trees look like I would have never seen
the faces of my beauty
children if I didn't have the ability to
see how blessed we are by Allah and
obedience is born out of gratitude
so thank him call upon him establish a
relationship with him forget about the
past take it out of being a ritual and
make it a spiritual experience Islam is
not something dubious unclear hazy it's
really straightforward he said it
changed his life he said he saw every
single episode that you had ever
recorded back here on the D show with
Shaikh sad and you are presently also a
instructor with Elmo glib yeah I'm one
of the I'm the latest instructor for
automotive Institute we're gonna get
back to that a little bit later but now
people want to know like celebrities
okay most of the people today they have
a favorite celebrity yeah you know if
that celebrity cuts their hair a certain
way they put their hair a certain way
that they you know the raise up the
skirt in this way they do the same thing
yeah did you have certain pop stars rock
stars that you were emulating
why would you scream like I mean if is
there someone that you met or if you
wanted to meet that you just go crazy
for I mean I was into pop stars obvious
ridiculous now that we know it's not
like I was in the pop stars I wouldn't
scream so like that Aerosmith I don't
know I saw have you met earlier
now Jovi that was before my day before
my day guys at that time I'll take about
one of my favorite bands and like I said
this is exclusively for you I've really
told anyone about this raging of some
machine yeah I don't know you probably
come here to Rage Against the Machine
Against the Machine they're one of my
favorite bands because they were
political they talked about real issues
and I felt like this is the type of
music that can make a difference you
know so I felt like there was substances
I didn't like pop music because I felt
like there's no substance to yeah
alright so I enjoyed punk rock and you
know a lot of punk rock bands even rock
bands they do talk about political
social issues yeah Rage Against the
Machine was one of those bands and yeah
I did look up to them yeah you know the
lead singer I would say was one of the
people that I really look up to yeah you
were there you've been there done that
now you're at this concert yeah
basically this is I would say one of the
turning points in my life because people
ask me like was there was there
moment that really stands out this is a
moment I would say although I did take
time but this was the one moment that
really stood out I went to a concert and
at this concert I remember until this
day there was floor seating and there
was like balcony seating in the back so
people on the balcony they could look
down on the crowd and the band and I was
sitting on the floor seed in the ground
seating and the band came on and
everybody started playing and the band
start playing everybody was having fun
everybody's having a good time and I
just paused for a moment and I have this
feeling and I don't want to say it's an
outer-body experience right I just want
to say that I could feel like it's
almost like I could look down upon
what's happening I could look down on
the situation so it's almost like I was
sitting up on the balcony I'm sitting on
the balcony and I looked down and I see
myself I see everyone there everyone's
just like dancing rocking it out into
the music and I'm like is this it like
is this my life like is that is that the
purpose of my life is just to try to
maximize my fun now people here are the
scene if we can paint the picture to
visual people yeah bobbing their heads
from side it's more like a drunk yeah
people are drunk Giambi's now it's like
zombies people yeah people that's how
you you're actually I'm having an
epiphany now you're having a moment
you're just like it was like it was a
moment of clarity is that one moment of
clarity that I had where through all
this all this chaos this chaos yeah
you're thinking serious yeah it became
serious at that moment I could look down
I can I can see it and that really
affected me to the point where my
friends sitting next to me she says to
me he said she yeah is she trying to
pass you something no no she wasn't
passing me anything she wasn't passing
me anything
but she says to me she noticed she said
is everything okay like she saw I mean
the color of my face changed like it
obviously it affected me and I was like
yeah I'm fine and I was like listen I
gotta go
like I can't be here right now like I
know this is not good for me I left I've
got my car and I drove that night
remember I drove for hours just thinking
about life and one of the things I asked
myself was where am I headed
so I plotted out my life
and I said let's say everything in my
life goes as planned right which never
happens anyway right
like you don't always get what you want
but I said let's say best-case scenario
I get what I want my band we got a
record deal which not many bands don't
really get record deals it's really
really rare that a band gets a record
deal because that was your dream yeah
that's the dream right
sounds like my band gets a record deal
we get signed we tour become rich and
famous right I spend my life doing what
I like doing doing music playing music
and then I'm like I fast forward I'm
like okay let me fast forward a couple
years five years ten years twenty years
thirty years then I'm like then what
right then I'm like okay now I'm sitting
on my deathbed then what what did I just
spend my life doing right there's got to
be more to life than this fun right and
then the other thing are you still 18
now are you 19 I'm a little bit older
than old boy yeah it's it's been a year
or two after that you're fairly you're
young yeah I'm young and that's you know
I was pretty mature for my age like I
said I did write and I wrote poetry I I
wrote lyrics for the band so I did think
about these type of things so at that at
that time I thought to myself even this
life even the life that I'm chasing I
know it's not perfect because I've been
to concerts I've been to parties I've
I've had the fun that you can have and
it just didn't it wasn't fulfilling
right it sounds like I find if I spend
my whole life doing this it's not gonna
all of a sudden become fulfilling right
so that I look back my life and I'm like
is that a wasted life and it seemed like
a wasted life and I said you know what I
need to figure out what my life is
really about cuz it's not definitely not
this it's definitely not chasing this
life and just trying to have fun that
can't be the purpose of my life and
that's why I started my journey now the
journey begins yeah the journey began
the journey that's what I became serious
that's when I was like you know what I
know happiness does not lie and chasing
the dunya
that I'm that much I figured out at that
point so what happens from here from
there I began looking at religions and
spirituality and you know one of the
things about
young person you tend to rebel against
those things that are around you so I
rebelled against the religion of my
family it's numb so I'm like obviously
that can't be the truth so that's the
last place I looked for the truth yeah
so you started did you get into
Christianity yeah I looked and I looked
and looked into not Hinduism but
Buddhism Christianity
I had a Jewish friend to talk to him for
a moment there I was like maybe you just
have to be spiritual right and that
didn't make sense and I remember I would
always have these questions right
because I was like if I'm gonna change
my life it has to be logical it has to
make sense and I have to be completely
comfortable with it
and I remember talking to like my
Christian friends and talking my Jewish
friends talking Buddhist even talking to
people or just like listen you just got
to be a good person doesn't matter you
know just just be good and I realized
that I always had issues like it was
never I always had question that they
couldn't answer right and obviously
would with other religions talk about
their questions like who comes to
Christianity for example the whole
Trinity business and all that like it
never made sense to me and coming from
the outside it really didn't make sense
to me like I just wasn't convinced and
nothing can miss me until I finally
finally went to my brother and I'm like
okay tell me about Islam let's do this
I'll have questions for you you can
let's see if you can answer it where
were some of these questions some of
these questions were some of the
questions were about why do I have to
worship God to make it make it to
paradise right things like that
questions of predestination for example
like if God has decided everything ahead
of time God knows what's gonna happen
and what's the point of me doing
anything if it sorry questions like that
which I didn't know back then but now I
know there's clear answers in Islam
Islam didn't provide you any ambiguous
yeah there's nothing ambiguous
everything they even like you take the
most taboo subjects right you take
polygamy you take you know cutting
people's hands off when they steal and
stuff like that if you look at it in
context if you look at if you look at
the the spirit of Islam you'll see it's
the most just way right and that is at
that point when I when those questions
were answered for me
there came a point where I was like I
don't have any more questions was
everything explained to a an
understanding now that look a young
adult such as yourself yeah it was clear
it was loose a purpose of life the
purpose of what you know when you die
yeah what you need to be doing here
everything was explained and evidence
because look many people say look
exactly religion is a personal choice
you just have had that faith he's got to
believe you just got to believe one of
those it wasn't and that's that's what I
heard from other religions and when it
came to slum my brother didn't tell me
even the other people that I was talking
to they didn't tell me listen I can't
explain this to you you just gotta
believe because that's a no-no for me at
that point I'm like peace out I don't
have nothin to do with this right when I
came in um they would answer my
questions and they would explain it to
you and it wouldn't make sense so there
came a point in my life at that point
where I was I said to myself I remember
clearly I said to myself if I do not
become Muslim right now it's because I'm
rejecting the truth because I know it to
be true
and my heart is comfortable with it
because that's the thing about dohave
but worshiping allah yet alone is that
your heart is comfortable with that
concept because that's part of our fifth
on it's part of our nature is to accept
to hate so at that moment I realize that
my heart acceptance it's it's it's pure
and if I still don't do it it's because
I'm rejecting the truth and at that
point is a matter of it's like two
people outside it seemed like a single
day that I changed what was it a single
day but it was a single day that I made
that decision to say you know what I
think it's time to submit you have peace
now are you happy yeah handle eyes
someone wrote you a check right now they
said you know here's a million dollars
contract come and be the lead singer for
this bad band would you take it
I want to do it I want to do you know
why I wouldn't do it cuz I know it's an
empty life I know it's an empty life and
and I know I mean a lot of times the
problem of the youth is they don't
understand that money and and and fame
and that kind of stuff it's not
fulfilling it's not frankly and one of
the problems is a lot of kids they don't
have it they just see all the people who
have it and they see them on TV and they
see them on the internet and some like
this and they look at their lives and
they assume it looks like their lives
are amazed
your lives are not amazing how many rock
stars have committed suicide one of my
favorite rock stars Kurt Cobain from
Nirvana nirvana I was just thinking that
yeah you committed suicide I couldn't I
couldn't believe it
let's write it right there we're gonna
take a break we're gonna we're gonna
pick up right there
suicide celebrities why are they doing
it they have all the money in the fame
we'll be right back here
Indonesia this is my family Betty has
always been stubborn he started having
his problems getting up to the fights
one night policeman told me father
come on get him from the station he's
locked up one fight here another fight
there his physical beam was great for
his ego but it left him empty if someone
who Eddie in his youth they would
predict that he'd be dead and the
outside people looking in today this is
the man everybody knew Eddie and then he
given moment you could have 70 women
that are running around the club looking
why I have to get out of this totally
right now at the end there was just a
boy it was a constant struggle there was
in her soul with broken at that moment
there was that emptiness in his eyes it
was a big round Tina's that I think I've
ever really seen in his eyes I'm running
here running there and mainly I'm
running that long way it was dr. Jekyll
mr. Hyde and he was struggling with that
but the effort was there there was a
conscious effort to make that switch you
back and start talking to his back with
it and he's fine as the good guy this
was the reality it was death
ladies consequence and if you wanted to
start sewing the slime is spiritual
anonymously but people didn't know who I
was
so what why are we doing this hands-on
take you serious you're living a dream
ten people were just stubbornly
resistant and I started looking at you
like you're you know from outer space I
have to be out there and trying to
convince people to be on the show of
that show aired I think that's when you
saw the full pollination come into the
home these guys change what's going on
here this is a machine I know see
someone changed the sees that character
changes to see positive changes in their
life it's a sign of God back here on the
D show from lead singer in a punk rock
band to peace and purpose living the way
the Creator wants you to live and at the
end nothing less than paradise avoiding
the Hellfire and this is something that
all the messengers of God they brought
and taught they gave the good news
didn't they obey God and you're gonna
get Jenna paradise disobey God live
according to your whims and desires and
your fancies you're gonna go to hell
fire on the day of judgment yeah and now
it's LOM provided all the rational
logical evidence before we get into that
tell us now suicide if these people out
all the money Whitney Houston yeah when
many of these people continue you
mentioned the personnel was dear to you
what's his name your honor
Kurt Cobain Kurt Cobain whatever their I
got all the money faith you had money
fame and he wasn't doing something look
that's the thing he wasn't doing he
wasn't doing his unfulfilling music
wasn't a pop star yeah he wasn't a
grunge rock musician like he was making
that he was playing the music that he
wanted to play and he's still committed
to it son you can't that void yeah you
can't you can't fill it only entered
into the night of thing nothing nothing
will fill that void except submitting to
the one who created you
that's the void you had now it's the
void I had is it still there how did a
lot of what is not there anymore it's
not there they're not talking how could
I mean I'm sure it looked at
seventeen-year-old 16 you're an adult
now right yeah
accountable in Islam what age now
puberty yeah you're you're an adult now
you have to make these decisions so for
those young adults that are out there
and they're just their minds are warped
with music they wake up to it they go to
sleep to it ya know marijuana drugs
drinking fitting in they can relate now
you know yeah you speak the language at
times yeah living that yeah what advice
do you have for them look one of the
things that I often talk about is being
real and opening your eyes and thinking
about the big questions and that's one
of the issues I think with being young
we tend to ignore the big questions
right we don't want to think about death
we don't want to think about the fact
that this may be our last moment to live
I may not make it home today this may be
my last interview rights may be your
last interview that's the reality of
life even a non-muslim own denied the
fact that he doesn't know what he's
gonna die even atheists somebody who
rejects God doesn't deny that fact those
are big questions and our Islam the
percent encouraged us to think about
those big questions he said Aikido made
victory had him and let that L mote he
said increase in remembering the
destroyer of desires death all right
that's the big question so if we think
about those things it'll bring us back
to reality right I don't think I don't
think young kids deny the fact that
we're gonna die they just don't think
about it all right they don't they don't
yeah they don't think about it so the
idea is you know bringing that bringing
the real questions you know asking
yourself the real questions that's what
did it for me now tell us before people
have to go all the way around the world
and accumulate all these bad deeds you
know blackened their heart and all the
trauma and everything now how can people
be sure how could they know that this
way of life that we're talking about
Islam's submission to the will of God is
indeed from the crater is not man-made
right how can they be sure what would
you encourage them to do listen the
thing about Islam is and in that we
don't have to do a lot of work right so
hey there's such a simple concept how
would you translate their pure
monotheism here I would translate to our
Heath as worshiping the one who created
you and gave you life it can take your
life away beautiful simple
that because he is the one who created
us he gave us life he gives us
sustenance he provides for us he's in
charge of all affairs he is the only one
who deserves our worship and our
devotion that is to hate right there
it's so simple nothing in create not
Jesus exactly Hamid I mean never praying
to them of course messengers of course
and that's one thing span a lot I
remember now
when thinking about Christianity and
Islam and those things I was like my
fifth thought told me I said why Jesus
like why do I have to go through
somebody to get to God alright if God
cares if he's the one that created me
why do I need people why don't need
intercessors right and it's unfortunate
in this day and age we have Muslims that
go to intercessors right when we have a
hundred now we have a pure religion no
intercessor no just a middleman no
secretary exactly legal only allies oh
and this is a power that a Muslim has to
have a connection with their Lord right
other hand the Muslim knows this this is
why when we go into such that we know
we're close to Allah is knowing it and
we call out sincerely to Allah so Jeff
so before we cut out can we say that's
to start right now you're at home
watching this yeah you know there's a
voice start asking the Creator alone for
guidance exactly that's that's one of
the things I did actually I I sincerely
I said God if you're out there guiding
me guide me describe min and it wasn't
it wasn't a matter of anything I just
purely wanted to I had that I was like
just show me what the truth is and if
you put down those barriers right I
don't care what your religion is here
Jew or Christian atheist if you're a
Muslim or doesn't practice you put down
all your preconceived notions all your
bears you put them down and you
sincerely make the out to Allah to God
and say oh God guide me to the truth
Allah will never leave you if I still
look 8 away he will make away simple is
that
yeah we're out of time tell us we have a
special class that you yeah I'm teaching
a class for al-muttalib it's called the
fit of chilling it's basically the
Islamic perspective on entertainment and
recreation okay the point of this class
is to find that balance in your life
because obviously as Muslims we submit
to Allah as though again our goal is to
Hereafter at the same time we don't
abandon the dunya all together right as
Muslims our goal is to lead a balanced
life and in that balance we find comfort
right where religion which is away from
extremism
right extremism meaning going too far or
not going far enough or not doing
anything at all so for example you
somebody who showers 20 times a day
that's extreme because he showers too
much
somebody doesn't shower at all that's
the other extreme the balance is in the
middle so the point of this class is to
find that balance in your life
in terms of entertainment and Recreation
so you so you lead a fulfilled life at
the same time you don't feel like oh I'm
Muslim so everything's all right now
yeah you know what to find that balance
in your life people can look you up at
where yeah I'm on Facebook sought to
salim i'm on twitter at sought to slay
me look me up and yeah may god almighty
the crater the heavens in the earth and
everybody say allah jesus said Aloha
that's the one guy but he rewards you
thank you exactly yeah see you next time
inshallah and there you have it another
person's story who was living this life
the wrong way and then he came to the
right way which was based on proof and
evidence is filling the void that was in
his heart that was missing it was
missing and Islam pride provided him
with that peace that contentment that
satisfaction Jesus brought Islam Moses
brought Islam Mohammed the last and
final messenger he brought Islam
submission to the will of God not to
your fancies your desires not worshiping
a man a monkey an elephant nothing in
creation but worshiping the one create
tour and we have the living miracle
today the verbatim Word of God the Quran
you can pick it up for free one eight
hundred six is to Islam and start asking
start asking because you know money
can't buy happiness nothing in this
world can fill that would accept you
turning to the creator and him guiding
you so ask for the guidance ask for the
guidance and when you get it you will
see that your whole life will turn
around and you'll truly be happy you
truly have success and at the end when
you die you have paradise that's right
and you'll avoid the Hellfire we'll see
you next time peace be unto you